99 of relationships that i've had that
haven't worked i i'm telling you right
now the relationships that haven't
worked where it was my fault and i look
back so i only look at the stuff that i
screwed up with and i've screwed up many
of them you know what they all have in
common i did not manage expectations up
front it's my fault i don't sit there
and say what the other person so
eventually i'm like yeah this
relationship didn't work out why you
didn't manage expectations you just saw
google gaga over the fact oh my gosh
she's so hot you screwed up so rather
here's where i stand is that good if you
like it it's not going to change this is
where i stand with this and it works out
that's what i think they do right and by
the way that's how we were in the
military
it was kind of like look i'm not looking
for wife i'm not looking for this but if
you want to have a good time no problem
anything outside of that i have no
desire to get married while i'm in the
army and the girl either said no i don't
like that or she said cool i respect
that great then let's go and if it's fun
we'll do it again if it's not this will
be the last time but it was all up front
managing that expectation and how long
have you been married now patrick
twelve and a half years but you know
what i say you know what i say about
marriage what do i say about marriage
the day i got married and i'm giving a
speech at in front of our wedding i said
let me tell you something about marriage
i don't know whether we're going to be
married for 50 years
but i do know we're going to be married
for one year we're going to take it one
year at a time um i said this in front
of 500 family members
i said
we're going to take this one year at a
time and none of you guys can create
unnecessary pressures for us because i
don't wanna say number two at my wedding
day i said do not ask my wife if she's
pregnant you're gonna have a problem
with me
nobody can ask my wife if she's pregnant
there's a lot of extra pressures for
having kids you're not going to come to
my website you guys have kids or not
when we do you'll find out about it i
want a lot of kids but if it doesn't
happen it's none of your business i
looked at both sides of the family don't
ask my wife about kids and don't ask us
about you know all this other stuff and
yeah marriage one year at a time we've
been married 12 and a half years we're
about to be 13 years i think we can make
it to 13. the reason why i say this is
the following reason some people say
he's got an agenda he's got this or he's
got that no
life changes people change situations
change i can't control the other person
i can control myself i don't walk on
water i don't have the expectation of
walking on water my standard is not to
be perfect that standard of perfection
ruins relationship the standard of
perfection ruins relationships the
standard of perfection rules friendship
all of that so listen
here's where i am i respect you we're
going to play the game i love you i'm
going to protect you i'm going to be my
best but at the same time let's take it
one year at a time it's worked out well
yeah i think the biggest thing
that's a very good point you made
earlier um the big thing for guys
especially is that like okay this is who
you are right just the core foundation
is make your money focus on your mindset
your fitness as a result you becoming a
better man guess what if you're in the
best positions possible for yourself
like for example i'm not myron mario's
not me you see flashy jewelry lifestyle
that's just me that's why i wrote right
but guess what regarding women and
dating this is who i am i'm not trying
to be somebody i'm not i likewise he's
very upfront very you know masculine
very who he is but guess what that's who
he is what's the result if you are who
you are and you prove yourself as a guy
i'm telling you right now that's all you
need to do you don't need to be me or
might just be yourself but at the same
time agree yourself mentally physically
and also money-wise
yeah i don't know i don't uh this
again i thought there's going to be a
[ __ ] ton of things but but yeah everyone
takes our clips and like oh i disagree
with this but then when you get the full
context of you what you're saying is for
men to be men by the way if you want
options increase your market value you
have to as simple as that like the days
of just being able to like you know kind
of have game or having like used to be
where you can have like do one thing
like well and like do really well with
it but like nowadays man with the the
pickiness of women how the mar the
dating marketplace has changed women
have more options than ever before you
really have to be a complete package if
you want to be able to get the dating
options that you want and on top of that
be able to retain girls keep them in
rotation whatever because if you got
like let's say you got game right but
you don't got any money or you don't not
the best-looking guy right um you'll be
able to get girls you might get laid
once or twice here or whatever it may be
but you're not going to be able to
retain that girl long term you're going
to lose her to some dude that has a [ __ ]
together whatever maybe that might have
less game than you or let's say you're a
very good looking guy you might get laid
every now and then but you're not able
to keep girls around or take them on
dates give them a good experience and
retention goes down or let's just say
you have only money well they're not
going to respect you because you don't
understand how to uh cognitively
stimulate her and get her to be aroused
by you and actually genuinely attracted
she's dealing with you just as a means
to me because you have financial
stability so we tell guys you need to be
the complete package you need to be in
shape you need to have game you need to
understand female nature you need to um
have your money on point so you can go
ahead and be the most marketable to the
largest demographic of girls there's
some girls that only want good looking
guys that are in shape cool now you're
in shape there's some girls that only
want guys that have money cool you can
get them chicks as well there's some
girls that want guys that you know have
a talking mouth talking p a good talking
game cool so that way you're the most
marketable to the largest amount of
women because we tell guys all the time
in today's
dating game you got to work volume you
got to be talking to a lot of girls and
to be able to talk to the most girls and
have the highest potential of success
you have to have the most attributes
will make you attractive to the largest
demographic of women and having all
these things in place not only will make
you more attractive make you happier as
a man in general but you're going to
have an abundance mindset and you're not
going to operate from a scarcity mindset
so many guys operate where it's like oh
my god i hope your legs below she likes
me let me try to impress her i'm like no
[ __ ] that [ __ ] it's not i hope she likes
me game it's take it or [ __ ] leave it
game comply goodbye this is how i am and
when you have that abundance mindset
even if the girl doesn't like you or she
gets offended by it she's gonna respect
you and i tell guys all the time a
girl's respect is more important than
her liking you because if she respects
you she's gonna be like okay you know
what this guy isn't kissing my ass this
guy isn't all about it uh you know
putting me on a pedestal whatever this
is different this is the refreshing let
me figure out what's going on here
because most girls are used to getting
their asses kissed for nothing more than
them being of
being a female and having a vagina so
when you come in like oh no that's not
how i operate or you got to do this or
you impress me
finally it puts her in a position where
she actually wants to be in she's
finally chasing a man's validation for
once and that makes you more attractive
and if it doesn't [ __ ] her find another
girl if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]
you